[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot live we
are here for a Hyrule warriors
definitive edition launch day livestream
brought to you by Nintendo switch I'm
chastity and with me today is my good
friend Ben djenka our resident expert in
all things Hyrule warriors hello there
hey how's it going and it's your
birthday happy birthday thank you
it's yes a great day thanks for joining
me for our livestream today on your
birthday everyone wish him happy
birthday were on all the chats right now
and we're gonna jump into the game
because this game is out today on
Nintendo switch you can play with a
friend you can play solo we're gonna
play solo today and give you a good look
of all the things that are new and HD HD
this time it's really bring a lot of
this game yeah i've been i've deep dived
into this it's basically all I've been
playing since I actually got it yeah but
it's it's good yeah I'm feeling it and
it includes every map character and
mission from both the dub the Wii U and
the Nintendo 3ds versions including all
of the original DLC yeah yeah so that's
a pretty good deal if you haven't played
this yet so you might as well today
today is the day you can so what are we
showing them first been uh so I think a
really good thing to jump into well just
do a free mode but I want to show off
the forsaken fortress level from from
when Wind Waker it's a winter stage and
it was previously only on the 3ds which
3ds is a wonderful piece of hardware but
it wasn't HD and now it's an H and now
it's HD and it's very pretty
yeah so when you play it in TV mode it's
in 1080 so this this is pretty wonderful
whoa look we got we got some cool
clothes but we're gonna wear this yes
the wild tunic look this is new so link
has his breath of the wild tunic Zelda
also has ortho donkey gear right quick
she's got her outfit from ring as well
real spiffy I'm into it very spiffy
but I think free I'm gonna bring link
along because he's my highest level
character and we're aware that that
tunic and then who are we teaming up
with my boy temple because if you want
the most on brand move for me to do on a
stream in a Hyrule warriors situation
it's gonna be picking tingled absolutely
I'm excited I haven't unlocked single
yet so I'm excited to see these fairies
check out these fairies so this is this
was on a 3ds but this is now on the
switch version as well and you can dress
them up you can feed them what kind of
things can you do with your fairy you're
pretty much like raising it right so you
you find food for it out in the field
and you feed it and it levels it up it
gets different skills so like this one
which is really great for me whenever I
lose all my hearts I get brought back to
life which is very nice and I've got
this opposite one where it starts me off
with like 1/4 of my hearts but I do like
8 times more damage or something so
there's kind of a good polar opposite
thing going on with the two that I found
so far but I'm gonna play it safe cool
yeah so we're gonna be playing this
until 1:00 p.m. Pacific time so let's
jump right in
so we're gonna go into that stage that
you selected which is forsaken fortress
yeah so it's loading up so how far into
this game is forsaken fortress it's
pretty far it's pretty far this is it's
after the main story it's after you do
the the additional storylines for
link'll and SIA then it opens up into
this alternate kind of there we go we
get the jams going there's there's more
crossovers that happen more more zelda
games cross over into other zelda games
which is pretty very nice so there goes
length in his breath the wild here so
for people who ever played this can you
talk a little bit about what the game is
like so it's it's it's an action game
for sure but it's it's basically like a
dinosaurs or a mousou game where it's
one really strong character going up
against just just thousands of things so
you're you're you're gonna end basically
every match with thousands of kills and
as you guys can see there's a map in the
top right this is really important for
gameplay you can see which areas need
help which areas your team has taken
over so that your team is in
blugh the enemies are in red and then
there are some thick red barriers in
certain areas that you can't get through
quite yet so what are you doing right
now so you're unlocking this was gonna
say a webinar it yeah this is one of the
kind of light puzzle things that we
throw in to kind of keep it really dull
de is you go and capture the bomb shop
so you can get access to the hammer that
would normally be inside of that chest
then you can use the hammer now to knock
knock over the switches that you can use
to take out this wall or open up doors
so I'm going to go and use hammer on the
switch that will then cause this boat
over here to blow away the block so we
can carry on yeah cool awesome so yeah
there's a lot of puzzles in here and you
have to find things to get through
certain areas nice it's really cool cuz
it's it's got like the the mousou stuff
but it also maintains a lot of the cool
Zelda elements with the sort of light
puzzle-solving also it's got such great
music it really does I'm really into all
the cool mixes that they do and yes we
are in chat on twitch and YouTube the
905 guys that are you guys answering
questions yes we will be so please shoot
your questions and I will ask them to
Bend for you because he's been playing a
lot of Hyrule warriors different
addition this week it's true yeah so he
can most likely answer those questions
for you you haven't quite finished the
entire game yet but you're pretty far
right i finished the main legend mode
all the way through with all the paths
and I've broken into Adventure mode a
little bit yeah but Adventure mode is
where you actually go through to unlock
a lot of a DLC stuff which is cool all
right so let me tell you a little bit
more about this game so like I said it
includes every map character and mission
from both the Wii U and Nintendo 3ds
versions including all the original DLC
plus there are some updates exclusive to
Nintendo switch versions so they have a
newly added breadth of the wild outfits
as you see here for blink and
we have and then all of the breath of
the wild amiibo are compatible with this
game and we'll be showing you that a
little bit later yeah and then we show
you the my ferry mode from the 3ds
version now has 3d rendered graphics and
there's two Wind Waker stages that are
available this is one of them and then
they have HD graphics for the first time
and also you can play two player co-op
mode by sharing a set of jaikon
controllers so you can hook this up in
the dock play it on your TV with a
friend just hand one joke onto them and
you guys can take on all these bad guys
together yeah it was I was actually kind
of really into how the coop works I got
the chance to try it a little bit with
with Michael hi I'm when we were
capturing first time that we did
split-screen
into it so do you does each of you take
one person on the team that you select
at the beginning
that's very nice like one so in this
situation if one of you would be like
one of you would be tingle yeah very
cool crime said hey happy birthday Ben
thank you I'm really happy it's this is
kind of like the best birthday scenario
this is pretty great this is so yeah
this game is new and HD it's 1080p 1.4
TV mode handheld is 720p for those
wondering and it's out just goes off
he's oh my god singles so great he's
doing doing his own thing he's living
his best life wow this is great I
haven't gotten to play with single yet
cuz it's pretty early on in the game
look at that what is he doing he's
really into using balloons and bombs
very distracting him it's it's wild that
is wild the monsters beat our allies in
the eastern path we must protect the
town thanks Hydra she's on top of your
course organ like he said looks fun it
is pretty fun yeah I like I'm a big fan
of Musso games and this it's a really
really good mashup I actually I played
the Wii version and I also played the
3ds
so you've played all of the versions so
now you're playing the switch version
I've got a pretty pretty good benchmark
on what's what's changed is my question
he's just he's doing his thing you know
it's grin I should tribe running like
that it's scientifically proven to make
you run faster in the game it's kind of
like how he gets around he'll just like
pop up bring it back in rein it in a bit
here oh this is the thing that kind of
happens in the stage a lot is you get
our good old bird pal showing up on
Waker as well kinda like the antagonist
through most of this was part of the
story leading up to a fight with one of
the versions so you actually don't even
fight him here you just chase him away
Oh which is kind of nice so I'm gonna go
up this way we're gonna take this top
area and then we're gonna converge back
in the middle one of the cool things
though is I'm kind of prepared for this
oh yeah I can't you send tingle
somewhere can you can we show them a
little that so you can direct him to go
somewhere by just making him yeah I lost
the central keep and it'd be good to
kind of get him like back over that way
so while I have link going up to the top
I can have him swoop back down and then
I can switch to him and take that place
over very useful so by doing yeah by
going into the menu and clicking command
you can command your other character to
go to a different area of your choice
pretty cool
yeah very useful Oh Nintendo says hi oh
hello how do you how's it going
I think there was a question from
grooving he said what then what appeals
to you about Musso games so I like that
it's it's kind of like a therapeutic
experience where you don't you don't
necessarily have to be like on the whole
time but just kind of get to relax and
like we just listen to some really cool
music yes
bunch of bad guys yeah I'm gonna pick
you back outside and say the same thing
it's very therapeutic especially after a
long day of work yeah yeah just like
laying back with a Nintendo switch
wherever I want and just hacking and
slashing you see having a Musel game on
my switch yes it's changed the game it
really has changed the game because I
can literally just lie in bed after work
and play this and it's fantastic it's so
fun OOP said ah good point
like a zone out game I get that yep
exactly it's a really good zone out game
which is ironic cuz like you're there's
so much going on but that's what it is
for me there's a lot of those barriers
huh
I think that's the last nice job you did
it you did it
well we'll be good here in a second yep
so Ben is playing in single-player and
will be playing in single-player through
this but as we mentioned before you can
also play in co-op and for the first
time they have split-screen co-op for
the game and Ben was mentioned that he
tried that out the other day with Micah
hi um and
yeah really good time yeah so I think it
might have been the first time Michael
he's awesome
Nintendo like I said yes I agree the
switch is so easy to play with yes this
much really change the game say there's
everything on this with and there's a
bunch of characters you can select from
so we're showing Lincoln single right
now but we're gonna show you some more
later so stay tuned for that and also
keep watching because we're gonna show
you what happens when you use a Meebo
with this game because you can do that
too soon as you unlock everything goes
breath of the wild amiibo which is
totally worth it this game it's a part
that's the whole thing it was all
playing that's why we picked tingle
because we're celebrating celebrating
Ben
very nice so you can target the enemies
so as you can see there's a red arrow
over the key boss so we're targeting the
enemy angers hitting the top bumper for
that right yeah it's kind of like a Z
target but not a Z target which is a
real good feel his running and there's
like confetti coming out this is so
festive he's really good I just I want
to let everyone you like just know that
tingle tingles in this game that's
almost like a sign point in itself so I
think you could use like the tingle
tuner at one point and that was like the
only way you could really do a thing
with him now you get to like let's do
all this which is fantastic it's pretty
great so can we show something with the
fairy what do you do with the fairy oh I
should be able to do it here in a second
with with link after I take this I'm
pretty curious about that because I have
not unlocked a fair yet but I'm pretty
early in yeah level up nicely done
worgen Winky said how much is the fight
combo based so it's it's kind of classic
Musso style so you've got like regular
combos off just kind of going through
your main attack button and then you
branch off depending on how many hit you
selected this if you just do one hit and
it just leads into this giant combo
where you're in
Wow it's there's a pretty good variety
you can actually level up your
characters and expand your combo base
which is also fantastic that's very cool
so you're constantly evolving the
character you're playing very cool so
we're also gonna show in this level some
fairy stuff and also the ocarina oh yeah
it's gonna say because I actually need
to go and go back to the main base right
now so we're about to take it over so
you can use it to teleport around the
field as long as you've touched on the
statues right here pour the borders miss
that guy nice yeah so with the ocarina
you can teleport to other owls statues
in the map so ocarina was also in the
3ds version it's here now you look at
the owl icons on your map and you can
transport to a location using that
ocarina so that's what's up with that
that's very cool very useful yeah so you
basically go up to the owl statues and
you activate them to use it it saves me
a lot of running and that I literally
just have to run all it from one point
of the map to the other without 9:05 guy
said does this game have motion controls
not that I found I believe it's it's
completely just regular button presses
which I mean
eluding oh my goodness it's just a silly
guy he's a balloon boy all right so
we've we've got the main base kind of
under control for now go back over and
take this and then we'll do a ferry
thing in a bit I just didn't oh that was
cool it's how we took back so you call
them out and they basically just wipe
out everything around you that's so
awesome which is it's an alternate way
to spend your magic it's really strong -
very nice very cool
so we miss out on the gold Skulltula but
we'll try it for the next level that we
play the next stage we play but with the
gold skulltulas you can get a piece of a
puzzle and then what happens there
what's you you Clark these these pieces
of art basically through getting with
different terms that pop up in the
different quadrants and the more you
collect it increases the potency of the
potions you can bring you've got these
healing potions if you're feeling down
you've got some damage going on you can
just repair yourself you can couple more
hearts by by getting more of them Tony
canna maker NSAID Hyrule warriors if
intimidation is still on my most wanted
switch list including to fighter 30th
Anniversary Collection BlazBlue yep and
more totally we're doing a lot of a lot
of those yeah the cross tag trial a lot
here at work as well
we've got to work together come on
cooperation is key Tetris Tetris are
good well I'm no God you can play as
them to start teleport on over to this
boss fight that's about to kill him an
ocarina get around there we go
oh wow suits a fight look at him
I recognize this guy from ocarina at the
time he's uh I was hoping and never run
into you again I can't believe this get
out of here with that Wow nice can you
do a fairy thing on not cool
so each each boss type has its own
weakness so you've got to shoot go
minutes I yeah arrows we jump back on
him and doing sorts of combos very cool
yeah
Marco where are you hey Marco said do I
need to play previous dynasty warrior
games to get used to the combat in this
game no it's very accessible this is
super accessible I did not play those
and I started playing this and it was
pretty easy to pick up honestly
yeah if you haven't tried a mousou game
or a dynasty warriors type game highly
recommended this is a great a great one
to actually get into for the first time
especially if you go to Zelda yeah and
if you haven't played pyroar is yet this
is the version to play because it has
all of the previous versions of the DLC
we do Marco's say happy birthday then
thank you Mark
and if you're just tuning in we are
playing Hyrule warriors definitive
edition on the Nintendo switch sponsored
by Nintendo switch having a great time
running around as link look at him in
his great breath of the wild gear and
we're here till 1 p.m. Pacific tab so
now having fun fighting birds
[Music]
the combos feel good yeah they have a
really good good variation to Mister
dreadful said that's the boulder from
link to the class
ah yes the molder holder from my
favorite so as we mentioned before the
fairies in here are not just support
characters you can raise them as your
own fine items for them you can feed
them and level them up and they each
have different elemental skills you can
find them puts and clothing customize
them and teach them different skills so
that's a really cool thing you can do
with the fairies in this game there we
can really mess with some of the
customization after we definitely after
we finished the forsaken fortress all
right I'm gonna put up on over this way
we're gonna go take it to the boss the
bus which you can see that's the
blinking marker right up in the top left
of the mini-map if you're looking
and link is the green arrow correct yeah
yeah yeah we've got some kind of hanging
out over there in the middle actually
let's tell it to meet us there
so yes you can command your other
character to meet you somewhere as he's
demonstrating right now very useful tell
me exactly what to target to which is
nice and then we can all all meet up on
the dude and just have a good old time
saving day yeah walk into this place
that is a dead end
worgen linky said how is the coop with
TJ cons as fighting change much or has a
lot of the differences with
single-player gaming so you have access
to everything that you would when you're
playing solo the button stuff is
obviously to have less buttons to handle
but it's it's all entirely there and
entirely doable I was actually kind of
surprised at how well it worked out
because you've got to have a way to
still kind of like mess with your I
don't use and do all that still solve
the puzzles while playing big levels so
we can call it a ferry again which will
clear out all of this stuff check it out
ferry time oh she's so cute
Wow terrible yeah good stuff so
everything's all cleared out now and we
can focus on the bigger guys the
soldiers do they do anything so they can
take keeps and stuff but they're like
kind of just there to kind of manage
things they don't do too much they don't
want to steal too much of the glory from
you which is nice and so we saved the
forsaken fortress single in link number
118 look you just dance the best of
friends oh man she's having a good time
ha any moves is I like how his butts
really a big part of this it's a whole
body dance it's an entire body dance
you could be linked and I'll be tabled
its kind of post about yeah I like it
alright cool
aside from tingle who is your favorite
character to play that's a question from
Rockman bionics so I really really liked
what they did with Ganondorf in this one
he's big and he looks like he's really
strong they have he's got these huge
gauntlets and I really like his design
so he's one of my favorite ones to play
isn't he just feel like you're really
powerful while you're going on yeah so
you get like story cutscenes either
Druce CGI stuff or you get these kind of
wall scroll deals
yeah it's very cute very cute Thank You
Carlos
[Music]
oh no he's got a save tetra not if link
has not on our watch I'll tell you that
much or Benz rather because he's playing
I'm just here to for support so it's all
good all right Wow look at that cool so
next up let's show them you want to show
them fairy stuff you want to show them
some characters let's let's go into in
the fairy mode and we can hit up the
characters while I'll be a good way to
do it yeah for sure
all right let's go into fairy mode very
really cool fairy Moon which also has a
certified Jam playing in the background
while you're doing it so tell us about
my fairy mode so the most important
thing is you can you can dress them up
and each different effects you can
actually like increase fire damage
alright so that that'll that'll increase
our fire damage we can also get the part
of it or you can get your casual
business casual affair I like business
casual fairy like that's that's too
fancy for us like we're pretty casual
folks yes
let's get business casual affair is it
these these pair of slacks yeah I only
have the one facepaint I'm fine it's
good yeah and we've got these these cool
hats you can put on the hats adorable
yeah let's do that
I feel like that that keeps everything
together so right now I wanna do that
one and then you've also got earrings or
accessories so we've got this cool
little oh oh let's put the earrings on
like her ears are very accentuated so we
should dress them up definitely yeah
alright so we've got our customization
suit best they approve they're into it
absolutely gorgeous see she's into the
business casual look so I don't have
much food oh so you can feed the fairies
but
you feed them and that's how you level
them up so I give them these delicious
[Music]
new wonderful things to discover and
then the other the thing that the
benefits they bring to you through
raising them are these skills and the
one that I have right now replenish your
hearts whenever you reach your life so
basically when you as you level up you
unlock more abilities so I'm level 9
right now I'm about to get my level 10
skill which is pretty good but you have
a whole list here that I have yet to
discover of just so many on deck look at
all the things you can do with fairies
once you get those fairies that's that's
very exciting I'm gonna turn the fairy
music back down a little bit yeah mr.
dreadful you know that and then to to
bow PVC 3 said who made this game it
says Koei Tecmo games yeah so you've got
the the professionals on it there they
know what they're doing they know what
they're doing and this is Hyrule
warriors definitive edition on Nintendo
switch sponsored by Nintendo switch now
let's show them some characters well
let's pick a speaking new level yeah go
pick a level you like fuen just messing
around yesterday and I think I'm into
this I like Scylla I love it's based off
of what am i well I didn't really play
it all the way through but I liked it a
lot because of its art style I'm a
trainer of Skyward Sword there we go
looks like they're painting on the Wii
which was really impressive you have a
couple of levels based off of that yeah
so as you can see here many warriors to
choose from let's go through a few of
them just to look through before we
select them so we've got EMPA and we've
also got Sheik here which these are kind
of like ocarina in time kind of
reimagining which is really cool and
you've got original characters like Lana
who was just four for Hyrule warriors
Zelda of course Ganondorf really into
how he looks in this one and darunia one
of the best characters from offering at
a time big fan of him
whenever you win he does his dance if
anyone remembers oh my goodness
and also princess route oh and then you
go into toilet princess Agatha we've
gotten mid now you can actually get
Twilight Midna as well how cool so
that's one that I have yet to unlock
over here I saw so work to do there's a
lot of characters yes fee you've got
some of these Skyward Sword characters
here more original characters and then
you're going into like the Majora's Mask
suffragette young late with his fierce
deity mask cool tingle of course
lincoler who was also an original
character Skull Kid I really like smoke
it'd still scare me though a little bit
and then you've got some of these these
really cool Wind Waker characters tetra
is fantastic and also the king the boat
the myth the king all hanging out and
you can pick who are you going with we
do we didn't link last time what does
lets go with was Zelda and her breath
the wild outfit excellent
yeah good choice good choice we take the
same fairy with us the one we just
dressed up I'm gonna bring Ganondorf yes
we were talking about him and I liked
him a lot
look at that Zelda and get in door
side-by-side together the way that we
all we all mix to go and let's do one of
these these original characters all
right i'll linkle's really cool we're
gonna go with all right let's go with
linkle yeah looks like a good
well-rounded team yeah we've got it's
just brute strength with Ganondorf we've
got speed and agility with Zelda and
we've got some really cool kind of all
over the place gun flip flipping combos
linkle's crazy yeah
if no one sees she's just fantastic in
forward to that yeah sweet tunes
so where are we so this is Skyward Sword
this is the dialogue there we go yeah
it's very cool all right let's go Zelda
so she's got a really quick kind of like
no stabby type of good combo
yeah she's got a lot of really cool ones
in her her gimmick kind of thing is that
she can power up her sword with me
so it'll actually change how some of her
abilities work so show more aggressively
slashed to going to shooting arrows it's
kind of really cool that you can you got
like basically two different sets of
moves also one of my my personal
favorites I'm really into the wild
outfit I like that outfit I was like her
original on for this too because she's
one of the ones where they kind of like
redesigned into like an original outfit
for its pretty legit so to some people
that are watching what's happening on
screen and they're wondering a little
bit because we're pretty far into the
game they're wondering what's going on
can you kind of talk through like what
you do in this game from a beginner
standpoint so basically the way this
game works is you have your army
fighting against another army and you've
kind of kind of fight your way in
advanced stages so right now we started
in the upper left corner fighting our
way down taking bases we go to kind of
diminish their people they're bringing
in make our fight a little bit
Rockman bionics says zelda is one of the
best characters to play in my opinion I
agree she's got it's it's crazy over
here
Winkle wrinkles and then her cool little
special appear for specific things I'm
doing to get up to next base that's
pretty satisfying those those combos
those moves yeah
so she as she hits people she builds up
this meter that's underneath there
special meter basically lets her kind of
funnel boobs into like a vortex almost
of just arrows so if you're wondering
these stages take about 15 to 20 minutes
depending on how quickly you go through
them is that about the amount of time
that you don't spend on most of these
stages it's it's nice to kind of get
like a quick session if you need to or
you can sit there and just play for like
six hours at a time but it yeah about
that long yeah so you getting a lot of
rupees so what can you do what can you
buy in this game will will show them a
little bit later yeah
so what have you been spending rupees on
Oh mostly operating through the the
talent trees me cuz I want to make sure
that whenever I play a new character I
have all of their all the abilities
wanna be able do
so I usually go that you can also spend
it on like if there's a new character
that you want to make sure is leveled up
you can pay to level up your character
with rupees up to whatever the highest
level you're so like with tingle after I
unlocked him I jumped a little bit of
money into him to make sure that he was
able to still kind of fight Judi 78 on
Twitch said what game is this this looks
amazing
this is Hyrule warriors definitive
edition on the Nintendo switch and it's
out today while playing on launch day
and with celebrating with launch day
livestream sponsored by Nintendo switch
and this is linkle chicken looks really
good whoo but we have a three character
team oh yeah that's right should we
command them to go to other places here
what's up where's everyone at right now
let's see let's get Ganondorf down here
to help the fight yeah this thing is the
site the real real dangerous I'm playing
as zelda right now so I can tell Winkle
to move out we can have her kind of
preemptively move up this way I think
something happens so we'll do that
sounds like you've played this a couple
times a little bit
yeah nice then we'll see Winkle running
past us on the bridge as we move over to
fight this guy a little bit of a canary
effect bosses are pretty cool yeah I
really like the effect if he wanted
society boss fights in that's not a
thing that really happens too much they
also did a really good job of like the
mixing of the targeting and walking and
moving and it it makes a weird blend of
kind of how's all the plays it's it
feels really good so we are in the chat
so if you're on Twitch or YouTube were
looking at your questions you've got
questions for Ben let me know and I'll
ask him for you and we're playing until
1:00 a.m. Pacific time and this is
Hyrule warriors definitive edition and
it's out today on switch and includes
every map every character every mission
from both the Wii U and Nintendo 3ds
versions including all the original DLC
it's all here to play all looking real
fresh real good yeah that's right so
playing in TV mode so it's 1080p right
now it's it's actually a huge noticeable
difference whatever but it looks very
nice get these toes I'm not I'm not too
big into the breakout that close I'm not
too big into doing the toes I'm not too
big and or all right yeah let's let's
see some Ganondorf action let's see
about he's about just getting in and
messing stuff up I like that exploding
fish said you guys are awesome you're
awesome thanks for watching
got him out of there kay brown 3 said
hey how's the performance on the docks
good actually it's still run normally
well it's it's a lower resolution 720p
it still still runs just about as well
as this actually is very impressive yeah
I have not had any problems so far
Wow look at him run he's very serious
he's on a mission he's got like a really
human ball character he's just he's
angry and he's strong he's a good he's a
good boy but he's a bad boy
I don't know it's he's like he's an
a-plus boy but I think he still still
still mean because he wants to like blow
up the world or whatever trust me when I
say he's also a good boy if he has
headphones what do you think he's
listening to you well he uh every single
enemy opening I've ever heard in the
history of time I was thinking it was a
very anime right and I'm into it it's
it's very very good yeah
everyone's got good runs in this game
everyone's got really good runs
especially two especially taking title
camps I love his design which they use
this in other games yeah that's what I'm
saying
like give me this Ganondorf Floyd
everywhere wow man messing things up
this guy no this this it's fine
everything's fine
[Laughter]
alright so now we've got our next bases
up I'm gonna tell Zelda come on over
this way cuz you're already closed
we go and what's all linkle to go over
to the fairy fountain and Ganondorf will
take this spot where already had and get
real tactical with it and we've got this
keep saboteur who thinks he can sneak
into our base but you can but he's been
sorely mistaken look at that he's so he
doesn't know what to do he's so powerful
defeat all the cheap saboteurs problems
Rahman backside emphases ein in this
game I'm very fond of him was very good
mix ever occur in and Skyward Sword
designs yeah Charles said combat systems
seemed good yes it's a plus feels good
looks good can't say feels good looks
good
probably not for the enemies doesn't
feel good for them they're getting beat
up so as you see Ben Starr getting the
boss and then sometimes I have these
spots right weak points so it got kind
of like a it reminds me a lot of wind
wakers kind of dodging every system it's
like if if you dodge out of the way of
something they'll be open after their
attack yeah and then you'll see like a
thing pop up over their head
if you diminish that that meter you'll
get like a really powerful attack on I
guess that's the kind of comparison that
I
like that you can take over this man I
can't get enough of watching like the
wrinkle is so anime real good like I'm
getting anime buyers I'm getting
Bayonetta vibes I'm just like it feels
good man yeah yeah yeah and sometimes
you take all the keeps you get the
Treasury see if we can open this up some
movies alright
Rockman said also some enemies get
vulnerable when certain sub weapons are
used on them yes there's elemental
effects if you bring the right weapons
in the battle it's a good time got more
more stuff going on here let's see
Zelda go on over this way and start
protecting this fight that Skyloft
captain let's tell link'll to go back
over here and we're going to take
Ganondorf down to the main base
hey Caleb said what does is the ko count
do /for just kind of keep measuring how
much how much damage how much damage you
did how badly you've messed these boys
up up it's it's one of the more
satisfying things and a mousou game to
just watch that count go up and just be
like I legitimately just knocked out
like 1,500 people to try and get get
through all this this stuff that I'm
doing yeah yeah BT on YouTube says does
this game have local / cult online co-op
not online local local place you player
clock mode by sharing a set of joy pond
controllers on one switch yeah it works
I kind of want to try more of it
oh there's a school Chula should we go
for it I think we should yeah because we
missed it the first time around let's do
it mr. Graff will sets cultural time so
if you let your your magic run out after
you
oh shoot there's no there's no owl
statues here so I can't tell Dorf down
here come in order to stay down here
okay someone else can go take care of
the skull Shula yeah let's go with the
cigs old up to go find that school to do
it Adrian said look stiff I want to see
some bosses oh you will
could live there are bosses in every
stage right fada DOMA earlier fought oh
we just got done fighting one of those
big monks here we go your toe monster
[Music]
hear it I hear it here it's freaking me
out
maybe it's on the other side of here so
we gotta use there we go there it is she
poked it you get illustration piece so
when you take out the gold Skulltula you
get a piece of the puzzle and you you
get to build up really cool pictures and
it also makes your potions better nice
Charles said what is the difficulty at
or is there a difficulty setting there
are at the beginning three different
difficulty levels and they're all pretty
skilled pretty well once you finish the
game it unlocks hero difficulty which if
you're feeling particularly crazy we can
definitely try that one out I haven't
yet but it's there for you so four
different difficulties and there are
certain neurological
like hard stuff so therein lies the
challenge
you got you got that stuff there if you
want to if you want to dive into it nice
yes and if you're just tuning in we have
a three-person team we're playing in
Skyloft Skyloft it's based on the
Skyward Sword
mm-hmm but Zelda here Ganondorf and
winkle and there are many characters to
choose from that you can unlock in this
game we haven't even unlocked all of
them yet there's so much true I've
dumped a considerable amount of time
into this which version so far is still
probably 40 or 50 Wow
so it's it's really nice too once you
finish the story it actually shows you
what you have let left to like unlock so
characters or different weapons and you
find those all in the adventure mode
which should be probably check out
you're a bit still so you advance the
story to unlock characters and put their
own moves and weapon types like fruit
bees and other items upgrade weapons and
craft badges which bolster your Warriors
abilities just bringing Gandalf back
down in less let's beat this this this
sword person take back this base take it
back
man
that is satisfying yeah 64 people I also
appreciate that they do like her special
like how how well did you do this is a
gauge we did we captured Skyloft back
very nice in the name of great job seem
endure the most unlikely of trios good
pose those swords though look at that
yeah he's also got the the Trident
weapon type which I haven't found yet
and
each weapon type has its own combo
strings and changes how the characters
play cool so it's a good time
awesome yeah let's show them adventure
mode next show them a little bit of
what's going on there after we watch
this this is the the postgame
celebration standing drifts got a strike
a cool pose got to yeah boss you can
actually one of the other deals as they
put up you can actually play as Ganon
mm-hmm like the giant like 30 foot tall
[Music]
it's like going knock out 5,000 people
just cuz for funsies which is kind of a
fun little thing so you get a bunch of
materials after the fact so this that's
the the part that I got picture links
face in turf looks real really angry
alright let's check out Adventure mode
yeah so Adventure mode is really cool
they've got just all these maps based on
all the different Zelda games and you
kind of play through different
challenges based on squares so say for
instance one of them will just be a
straightforward battle another one will
be like hey go and fight three bosses or
you'll even have ones it'll be like
quizzes so there's one of these I don't
know which square it was but it's like
here's the Ocarina of Time quiz and you
just fight through rooms or it proposes
questions like who is
this or whose secret identity is this
and if you this is where you got tingle
right yes I got I got to know up here
yeah on this square so if you want to
unlock tingle treat find a mother that's
where tingle is and you got a fairy in
here to us yeah both the fairies are
from this area so we've got one here I'm
not sure which one it was and I think
over this way yeah it's on on this
square cool so yeah should we show them
something in there so we can unlock
impose other weapon here yes I'm uh I
think I'm going to try to go for that a
rank victory here so we've got to do
defeat the commanders of two armies and
we have to play got this giant blade
before tea got a pretty good bigger take
our trusty fairy are very dressed up
yeah I want us I can't wait to get this
yeah get it today dude do that thing do
it it's on the switch battle information
screen battle
this is an interesting situation there's
yellow on the map now so what is that
about three armies fighting off oh and
we've got to take out both of them Wow
so here's how does that compare it's a
little bit more to manage but it's not
really cool like ninja yeah this might
actually be like appropriate challenge
levels so I might actually have to try
so this is proving a challenge for you
so I'm like man it's taking a bit to
capture this captured that Keith good
job yeah we're doing it Charles said how
can you go wrong with a really big sword
indeed true I've learned anything from
anime and power range we're gonna go
this way I'm gonna take this key from
the other group all right
see if we can kind of keep them nice
area
whoo throughout everyone nicely done
yeah you gotta use that that big sword
yeah Hika said usually the weapons are a
challenge might need to level her up a
bit see we'll do the best we can
what will go for it we'll see what
happened yes hopefully it'll it'll work
out but in the meantime so you play the
other versions of this Rick is asking on
YouTube how long do you say it take to
finish the game and 100% on everything
har percent of everything that's a lie
so I I've never managed 100% it and also
this since this is like everything from
the Wii U and the DLC it's there's a lot
going on so plenty of hours for you
like I said I've I've got like 40 or 50
hours in it now and I finished the story
some of the characters I still have like
there's there's a lot a lot of content
here
this makes me just want to play and
watch anime and listen to and matrix
that's one of the best things about
Musso games to listen your own music you
get those actual anime openings going we
got here we call it uh Oh Oh a box
inside a box very clearly again no I
could see maybe some some cool clothes
on I like it
your fairies very excited it's like ah
perfect this is just for me oh we've
been we've been locked inside of here
now we have to fight our way out I
wasn't prepared
[Music]
yes if you look up at the map guys you
can see what's going on with the three
different armies so the blue is looking
pretty good right now they'd taken over
like the entire middle but then we have
the red team's not doing too much right
now but the yellow teams kind of spread
out I call them a whole bunch of
reinforcements yes the north squares
about to go away oh geez I'm gonna try
to there are no owl statues here I'm
picking all the ones that don't have
Alice tattoos yeah with the owl statues
if you miss this for for their Alice
tattoos in certain stages and you can
use the ocarina to transport yourself
between those Alice statues I'm gonna
try to take out I'm gonna make a bold
move right now real real spicy choice
I'm gonna try to take out the red
commander Wow you're going for I'm just
I appreciate this is something's gotta
give and it's it's getting pretty
intense so you targeted him
you're trying your best wow that looks
cool though she still got about half
well less than half a meter okay
you're putting in work we're doing it
we're doing it we're doing it all right
there's not much left you can do it you
can do it yeah okay excellent
now we have one other Commander to get
that's gonna significantly take down the
red presidents which is great and now I
need to get back to my base which might
actually fall this might might have been
the wrong decision well we tried I try
to get there as fast as I can
this way so when you're getting all
these materials what are they for I use
them to build up upgrades and use them
to upgrade your characters oh man this
there's a lot going on wow this is a
crowded room all right so we use our
magic and we're gonna go crazy
defeated 1,000 enemies it's it's going
off everything's just everything's
blowing up we're saving the base here we
go
final clearing attack to bring
everything back together let's get this
guy out of here
oh no no maybe what happened
what's with what's here Oh some story
developments okay some some crazy things
were happening can you uh so we won
[Music]
who's better at midnight I like I like
him a bit more very proud she's got that
really big knife which is a cool thing
Ben does great too though you get both
versions at midnight and then she's
gonna put it right inside of it she
doesn't even have to touch it great good
job I was real worried there for a
second but you did it oh yeah we got the
a rank yes and we got we got the weapon
that we were something that's good
Oh naginata so now Impa has her her
secondary weapon type aa sweet kokkuri
been nice Oh got a new headband Ferrari
what's do some amiibo stuff you wanna oh
yeah definitely
we've got all these really cool meat
over here hanging out so all the breath
of wild amiibo are compatible with this
games we're going to show you some of
those and then yeah you can use up to
five amiibo per day got this really cool
boy see what we get a cool unlock sound
almost and from my understanding the the
rewards are based off of what amiibo use
but you can use anything so we've also
got let's use the Zelda from the breath
of the wild it should give us something
from the other it should give us
something for Zelda oh oh great so it'll
be kind of good let's find out there you
go yeah there we go a new a new sword
awesome then we've also got breath of
the wild link with his bow just want to
use that one see if we get fire rod and
then the last the last is all the one
we're gonna use just to kind of see what
happens with Ocarina of Time link see if
we still get some links entered loot oh
so you can all double link you can't
double wink you're getting too greedy at
that got it but that's okay because we
brought we brought the real fiery spicy
boy Charizard we're gonna see what he
gets us
where we get and we go oh no that's so
on grin I don't know if that's that's
cool
there we are alright yeah so you can use
up to five amiibo per day to get random
weapons and rupees and the breath of the
wild amuel will work but you can't use
two different versions of link as we
just learned so there you go that's what
you do with amiibo alright so we have
we're about we have 30 minutes left so
do you want to do another stage the
other one I see someone asking in the
chat does it have a story is just
clearing maps and leveling up so when
you want to do the story mode you're
looking for legend and basically this is
the main progression that'll take you
through all of these levels and there's
their Story cutscenes though basically
the plot involves just the different
timelines for Zelda crossing into each
other that's why you get characters from
you got the the Ocarina of Time timeline
up here where it branches off then
you've got the Twilight stuff and then
you've also got Skyward Sword and you
get characters from them showing up they
all kind of come together and then you
all y'all come together as a group and
you don't fight Ganon because that's
what you do all right we could do
another level and we can do more
adventure stuff so that it gets kind of
kind of crazy yeah that was we weren't
sure what was gonna go down yeah finally
played pretty exciting got a weapon for
result if we go over that way
so say oh so this is the other thing so
when you're you're here on this map
you'll see that up for the a rank
victory it says that you it requires a
search to find this thing that's for
tingle so what you got to do is you
actually go into this slot on the map
and you can use one of the items that
you get for clearing the maps to kind of
do so so if you're like oh well what do
I have to look at you use the compass
yeah and you discover that there's
something going on up there where it's
sparkling Oh interesting oh I'm gonna
use this item up here to blow open a
hole as well and from there you get
access to
reward now we know if we get the a ring
victory we'll get a whole heart
container for race for our good good boy
good boy
feed the Warriors on time so you get to
fight all of the the main dudes from
ocarina of time I guess all right who
shall we choose yes we've had too many
good people here let's let's do Volga
he's a real real dangerous kind of
dragon dragon guys look at that he's
based on our character but he's he's
also kind of original for this though
like this version of him cool well we'll
run around as him sounds good some Volda
action extra effective item attacks some
enemies leave an opening before
performing certain attacks cool give the
sweet tips alright so yeah wow this uh
this map is very circular there's a lot
of paths that go towards the middle and
yet the enemies are
I take it over most of it right now yes
we're gonna look take all that make
quick work of that so the really cool
thing about book is he's basically
transforming dragon so he he has moves
that literally just le lipo out like his
wings or it'll pull out like a dragon
arm to hit people with fire or one
reacts descriptors in that's cool wow
he's just spinning that thing yeah he's
real good
worgen linky said cool it has a lot of
different things really thinking of
getting it dude jump in if you have
mousou resulta you owe it to yourself to
pick it up without a doubt it's there's
so much stuff to do in it and it's it's
one of my favorite kind of games
it looks good yeah jump on in good yeah
and if you're just tuning in we're
playing Hyrule warriors definitive
edition on the Nintendo switch brought
to you by Nintendo switch and my name is
Jessie and this is Ben and he's playing
and we're having a good old time yeah
with the boulder what you get the other
really cool thing that I like to like to
do is seeing all the different
animations for opening up the boxes
because each character has their own
kind of personality I've done it I've
gotten the fairy clothes I'm very
excited about this more clothes for my
fairy friends I'm gonna swoop on over
this
[Music]
I'm gonna go through the updates that
are exclusive to the switch version
again because I read that at the
beginning of the stream so we have the
newly added breath of the wild outfits
for Lincoln Zelda
all the front three wild amiibo are
compatible with the game my fairy mode
from the 3ds version now has 3d rendered
graphics to winwaker sages are available
which we played earlier if you missed
that just check out the replay and those
have HD graphics for the first time and
you can play two player co-op mode by
sharing a set of joy icon controllers so
that's what you have to look forward to
in this switch version boom boom there
it is let's clear out this base
enemy troops withdrew show them what's
what
so if I've already beaten one of those
fire arrows which is great we're just
kind of cruising around here I must go
down this way and then we'll work our
way up around I kind of I like that you
couldn't even do like the the stuff to
kind of tactically tell your agents
where to go and my favorite thing is
still going with just one character like
doing the work cuz that think that's the
fantasy of these games doing oils like
you're you're one person army and you're
here they just do everything
[Music]
gimme just money that time but that's
fine
money's money is a good thing keep Alana
safe someone's coming out of base here
you go head them off outpost captain so
when you take out those at post
captain's then your team takes over that
outpost they'll have to come back over
to take it out and occasionally you'll
have like certain bases we'll put out
certain enemy and you have to take those
bases back so there's there's a better
kind of strategy with that
which one's your magic meter for the
fairies at the green mr. green one so I
can do a fairy attack right now like I
can call out magic I've also got two
special move switches pretty good nice
which is those jams jeans or 20% rock
bands that can you bring them more than
one character into the adventure mode
Maps or is that addition only for the
story mode so it depends on the
adventure it depends on the adventure oh
god this is not gonna work out for me
I was wondering who's gonna be the
yellow faction and just kept them here
what so there's a good surprise Wow
check out the cool yeah take out that
golden chicken that gold chickens cool
though all right extra crispy
perfect all right back to the question
can you bring more than one character
into adventure mode mass it depends on
the adventure mode some of them you will
restrict your character only using one
some of them will let you pick a plus
ship it
we've reached peak pond and I don't know
if we can ever top the Hat
keep the puns coming please yes we're
big fans
I live for puns puns are the best kind
of jokes
Wow he's very angry rage yeah I didn't
really place him much initially yeah and
then I gave him a go for this and oh
yeah Wow
he's also really really good at juggling
witches let's take this base alright
yeah the maps looking pretty blue so
we're doing a great job here very time
so this is actually an important place
to fill out to take because they have a
fairy fairy you actually take it and we
use it because in the the middle zone
here it's got the fire on it so it's
it's basically enchanted and I'll take
damage if I'm if I'm inside of it but I
can dispel that using the fairy from
this space so if I go over here and I
equip it I can bring it in here and we
can bring the fight to darunia boom and
now we're good to go
real strong guys
what kind of upset the because I'm
fighting him I wanted to see his dance
dances like his best thing Oh God rocks
he's got a whole bunch of towels in here
I've got a lot of power I clear them out
yes yeah that was a real good surprise
[Music]
we did it yay
perfect timing see we have about 20
minutes left in the streams we could do
one more I like it
one last one chat who would you like to
see you what characters would you like
to see yeah if you saw anyone on the
other characters like screw ya Oh
I'll do my best to play them for you we
can form a team and we can use one from
Ben's choice and one from the chat's
choice all right so I'm not playing on
the easiest note I'm playing I think
this is I think this map might be easy
but also my vote goes pretty beefy he's
level 27 and he's got a very strong
weapon he's also just a very very strong
character yeah skull kid just go could
be a good time all right two votes for
Skull Kid oh we got hearings cute all
right let's go back into a different
mode then cool mode of your choice was
head up free mode
just do the water the water level come
on temple wait go there oh you have 18
minutes good Skyloft let's try the the
Gerudo desert ok toys a bit time are we
gonna I feel like we've got to go to
Hyrule Field bring it on home yeah
people can I bring into this one three
great alright so we had two votes for
Skull Kid in the chat if the chat has
any other votes let us know who you'd
like us to include on our team come in
check and see what I've got for a swell
kid level up wise let's check out this
talk through what you're doing so you've
got three different areas you can level
up here your character and which is
attack defense and assist attack is
basically your main line is for getting
all of your your combos unlocked and
then you you build out into the bottom
area which is for your special attacks
and the top area which is stuff like
doing damage to people while they're
blocking cool submit you just power
yourself up through it which is a real
good time think of Skull Kid a little
bit a little bit of help here just to
make sure that you are Elric voted for
linkle alright bring linkle back on the
team and then pick one new character
besides that of your choice Ben alright
I mean cool we got Skull Kid we're gonna
bring in linkle and Ben's gonna choose
another character as well drew pew pew
said is this one player this is what
you're watching is one player mode but
there's also two players and if you can
play a local co-op yeah and each of you
can have a joy con and you can play
together split-screen Tetris do you want
to link it with tetra uh we could do
link lan touch right because yeah oh
just do that whole section yeah that's a
real good section of characters let's do
it cool we got linkle who is amazing and
then it also works out really well too
because I have to she's she's fantastic
what a cutie
[Music]
with this museum yeah and this'll be the
last stage that we play in our stream
but we've been having a lot of fun
playing Hyrule warriors definitive
edition on the Nintendo switch sponsored
by Nintendo's switch yeah good stuff
how can you play us online I don't
believe so I don't think so but you
could play it in bed
that's was to me pretty good all right
here we are so I think this is when you
you revisit Hyrule Field the Hyrule
Field stage which is right outside of
Hyrule Castle all right so let's let's
take a look at what we got here there's
a whole lot of red which is the enemy
team let's good linkle down here to the
south field key will swing off over this
way so it does does what Skull Kid does
he just laughs and dances all the time
which is a hundred percent on brand Oh
Ganondorf is here too nice this is this
is a good old time
I beams it's all here
[Music]
illegals already here perfect start
taking this key right away yes some cool
case reloads get back in here yeah I
hope we see more linkle in in other
places
ah it's linked he's here hey link
how's it going I actually just realized
I think this is a stage where you play
as the bad guys so we're gonna have to
we have to fight link really that's
gonna be a fun time
all right who is right next oh it's link
hello it's good to see you
there's question to chat about the
characters in this game besides what we
saw so I'm just gonna go through the
full list so we have link Princess Zelda
Impa lana sheik darunia princess Rudo
Midna Agatha fee Ganondorf Zant here
ahem SIA Volga Wiz ro totally Midna
young link tingle tetra King Daphne's
Skull Kid linkle medley mer mer in Marin
tune Zelda
Ravi oh and Yuga is what I'm seeing I
think there might be one more does this
game have any new breath of wild
additions question on twitch yes it has
outfits from breath of the wild and
amiibo capability so you have the newly
added breath little wild outfits for
Link and Zelda and you all have all the
breath of while amiibo compatible with
the game
oh that that I beam is very good yeah
about 12 minutes left
we're gonna play through this entire
mission you can do it yeah I'm gonna
[Music]
stay here I guess we can't we can't play
the tetri yet she's still locked out cuz
we got to progress to a thing but gonna
help her out here he seems to be in the
middle of an intense fight oh yeah it
was it's a real real mess over here
there we go
we're going to take this place up here
to see stop getting reinforcements
coming and messing with everything
what's up everyone my name's go kid
this is a pretty good team
yeah I'm digging it no I don't even got
a chance to do much with I know she's
good yes hahndorf a little late to the
party but that's okay
glad you could make it touch your buddy
it's a party over here
okay smoke is here he's guys good
although he dances all the time so good
styling on him all right captain
excellent job yeah we're clearing out
this map that's it's coming together
yes Skull Kid well if it's right so it's
there nothing it's okay boys were
playing is spoken so it's a bit of a
cannon place it works he would do this
I'm gonna keep Winkle down there it's
hell Skull Kid to move up over this way
so he can take that and we're gonna
switch back to link one we're gonna
fight these things that was go away stop
in this plan she got something some
people trying to try to sneak in how's
it going ever good to see you
mmm checkpoint
[Music]
so stylish it's the only only way to do
it when you're like oh yeah
it's really answers have fun everyone
amen anytime
happy to help okay we did it yeah gamer
- 9 - what console is on this is
Nintendo switch its launch day for
Hyrule warriors - pit edition on the
switch that sweet sweet Zelda Musso
crossover is finally on switch I'm very
very excited yes it is split screen if
you play in TV where you can split
screen it you can split screen it Oh out
of TV mode as well right yeah please
take one joke on each I had these guys
off at the pass trying to move in oh now
the main keep is open - Zelda Zelda
what's up yeah look at look you're
playing with her breath the wild outfit
her design in this game is really good
yeah
very into it very stylish watch out
fazil de
go into town I'll let you down
nice
we got link trying to move in on the
base well everything's happening all at
once everything is some try catch him to
go get it tetra Luc cars had turned this
from mildly curious to must buy cheers
guys you're welcome yeah anytime dude
happy game excited for you to jump in
yeah there we go
[Music]
sorry link here my dude today is such a
day there we go
look down the stream link in the enemy
yes it's right now why online this is
that crazy can't believe the things
you'll see ya
happy happy whenever we can even help
people find out more about it being a
beginner
alright
link oh who are you gonna fight now
Zelda Zelda I'm sorry does all I mean it
I gotta do something we're doing great
though look how much glue is on this map
a lot of blue
I know exactly what story machine so I
know where we are I know what's
happening
yeah
watch out Zelda
down here floating nice juggle under the
objective pops up defeat way ahead of
you game perfect there you go call it
the ferry again very time went on good
stuff alright does that keep is taking
the stick this one over here while we're
at it we're having said what's the main
premise to control the majority of the
map before time runs out so it's it's
kind of a delicate balance of stopping
there reinforcements by controlling
their areas so you've gotta kind of like
run around and keep track of stuff then
there will be important people that pop
up on the map like right now
link is actually making his way towards
our base so I'm actually gonna go I'm
gonna tell Skull Kid to kind of
intercept them so when I'm done with
this base as Tetra I can just switch to
Skull Kid and fight
so you gotta kind of keep an eye on like
commander's special units as they're
going to in from places to something
from taking over your territory and
basically ultimate goal is to stop them
from taking over your base and take over
their base zelve is on the move again
hey Linc how's it going good to see you
again use an entire super just not well
you think it's true it's only the hero
of
oh hi Ganondorf little late to the party
again glad you showed up but thank you
Super Mario appreciate appreciate it
whoa he's doing a special move there
dangerous just doing another one we have
you tuned in late if you're wandering
high rewards definitive edition includes
every Matt character and mission from
both the Wii U and then 10 to 3 es
versions including all the original DLC
so that's what you get with this version
quite a bit and yeah there's a bunch of
exclusives to turn a switch version
including the breadth of the wild
outfits with a wild amiibo compatibility
my fairy mode is now in 3d rendered
graphics which was from the previous
version to win waker stages and
two-player co-op mode by sharing a set
of johan controllers as you're watching
it here in TV mode the game is in 1080p
one docks and handheld is 720p and it's
out today today is launch day that's why
we're playing it and you can get that
for $59.99 on your Nintendo switch and
is developed by Koei Tecmo games
so everything's kind of like because I
think Lincoln's all to come back but
three times during this I have to worry
it's real intense there we go that's
good I think yeah I think we did it yeah
did you think yep yes right on time too
is 12:15 I look at that difficult IMing
we beat Lincoln Zelda we sure did the
heroes that we're usually used to where
our enemies the same room see a little
bit of a cutscene mm-hmm
ganondorf's real stoked about finding
the other pieces of the Triforce bring
them together
Lucar said easy to pick up and get in
see my seven-year-old is loving the look
of this yes definitely definitely and
there are different difficulties and you
could play on the easiest difficulty and
have a lot of fun with it yeah
admittedly that is how I'm playing so I
can breeze through this but it's super
fun and easy to get into and the combat
is not too complicated to you it's like
two buttons it's two buttons and
combination which way you press them
they're good it's it's a good time yeah
all right we're gonna wrap this thing up
yes job today you did it dude happy
birthday thank you again yeah yeah all
right and thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you next time thanks to
Nintendo switch for sponsoring the
stream have a good weekend
see you later
[Music]
you